the Ron Burgundy podcast yes let's talk
about it it's a very very exciting you
have your own podcast you call it
exciting I got shanghaied what do you
what are you talking I didn't know what
a podcast was I thought it was my own
talk show on television
turns out I'm thrown into you know a
padded room with a sweaty microphone
wait when you agreed to do a podcast you
didn't know what it was it was too much
money to say no you've done some
important work - is this true I'm told
right by my people
that you crack the Zodiac killer case on
your podcast right we did so true crimes
and mysteries they're very popular very
popular on pot yeah so we cracked the
Zodiac killer you did this is a that's a
murder mystery that's been going on law
enforcement and it's been they haven't
solved it's been unsolved for Oh God I
don't know 35 40 at least yeah I seem to
know a little more about it than you do
but look you it sounds you should come
and do my podcast for me yeah but yeah
we revealed to the audience that it was
Ted Cruz
and it's exciting to you know break
information like that out to people
that's uh did you have a good evidence
really good evidence you want to get
specific like top-notch evidence like
evidence that anyone in police work
would go like what this is good evidence
below okay
where'd you get this yeah where you bite
into evidence shop what's going on here
yeah this evidence is so good it seems
fishy yeah but no we got him tail so
anyway Ted if you're watching watch out
we know you've named him as the killer
but he's still free and no no no as far
as I know I don't know what I don't know
what he does yeah okay all right
what's in store for season two of the
podcast I mean I'm you set us pretty
high bar for season one if you're
solving cases like that what do you got
solving cases a season one we were stuck
in an elevator for one podcast we did
one for my haunted garage what else we
interviewed RuPaul mm-hmm yeah so we
pretty much climb the mountain yeah
season two will be a bit of a letdown
yeah that's always we're not really
trying that hard yeah and some of them
are just 45 minutes of dead air no I'm
gonna give you a little advice when
you're promoting something you want to
make it sound you want to build it up
well but I've never lied to my viewers
so I'd like to build it up look you
can't make chicken salad out of chicken
oh you heard it from the man himself he
makes a good case you gotta listen to
nothing good season season two of the
Ron Burgundy podcast is available today
wherever wherever you listen to me yeah
whatever if you find out tell me